as rumors swirl that Brad Pitt and Emily
radakowski might be an item it's a
really strong entertaining entertaining
story a source confirms to ET that the
two have been hanging out but it's very
casual Emily's fresh off a breakup
earlier this month she filed for divorce
from her husband Sebastian bear mcleard
after four years of marriage
meanwhile Brad who's split from Angelina
Jolie back in 2019 is still embroiled in
a legal battle with his ex and according
to E.T Source Brad and Em are friends
and neither are looking for anything
serious right now
Emily has yet to speak out about her
split from the film producer amid
allegations that he cheated on her but
she has hinted at her newly single
status on Tick Tock teasing that her dog
is the only man she wants in bed with
her and revealing that she's thinking
about getting back in the dating game
with this clip under a patriarchy
there's this premise of like men getting
women like getting them pulling them um
like there's something to possess
um which I feel as a recently single
person who's thinking about dating and
stuff I've really seen that with my
friends and with the conversations kind
of around it while we wait and see how
things play out between the model and
the bullet train star we do know they
have one very important thing in common
kiddos Emily shares a one-year-old son
Sylvester with her ex
he's such a baby right now I'm just
interested in keeping him safe and happy
while the Oscar winner has six kids with
Angie I love them to find their own way
find things they're interested in and
find their own voice I'm Brad He's one
proud dad when it caught up with the
actor in August he gushed over his 16
year old daughter Shiloh she's recently
gone viral for her mad dance skills is
easy
[Music]
[Music]
we all fell in love with the video of
Shiloh dancing
yeah
yeah oh I know me too that girl is bad
yeah it brings a tear to the eye I don't
know where she got it from because come
on Mr two left feed here
[Music]
dog
[Music]